but this is why I say more than women  are for the streets and they want to  stay in the streets because when you've  got a man that is all you want to show  is that a bit of commitment from you  you're like no no no no no no the Rave  is so important I'm going out my girls  are so important my man but that seems a  little bit far-fetched because nobody  said I'm going out no matter what you  said or I'm gonna go and see him but  it's when we asked you the question when  we we asked you if he said this what  would you do yeah and you said no I  would still do what I'm gonna do okay no  I that's that's not agreeable that's  that's not feminine that's argumentative